es lo sucedido
ucrania ha pedido que se saque a rusia
del consejo de seguridad de la onu es
posible esta medida y en que afectaría
al futuro de una organización que nació
para el mantenimiento de la paz
prácticamente es absolutamente imposible
retirar a rusia porque la única forma
debido a la carta de las naciones unidas
que tienen para expulsar un miembro es a
través del consejo de seguridad y el
consejo de seguridad rusia tiene un
derecho a veto puede expresar esa
expulsión por lo cual va a quedar
siempre nula es decir esa posibilidad
por la misma organización que tiene el
consejo de seguridad es absolutamente
imposible si es posible en avanzar en la
corte penal internacional que se creó a
las claras luego del estatuto de roma
del 98 que permite el enjuiciamiento de
estos crímenes y también por la corte de
la haya debido a que las pruebas que
presentó ucrania y que algunos de sus
aliados compartieron también parecen ser
de ninguna manera este que pueda
combatirse
si vista la imposibilidad de frenar a la
invasión rusa ha quedado obsoleto el
papel de la onu y su consejo de
seguridad en la esfera internacional
totalmente decir las naciones unidas ha
sido un paliativo para los conflictos ha
entrado a la reconstrucción ha hecho un
gran trabajo en las posguerras pero no
pudo prevenir ninguna por la propia
estructura que tiene en su propio
consejo de seguridad que él con 90
occidente por ejemplo eeuu no lo es lo
hace china o rusia ninguno de los
conflictos terminan resolviéndose por
eso se prolongan y por eso termina
teniendo un enorme poderío la otan
porque de alguna manera todo lo que no
se resuelve a través de las naciones
unidas intenta notar resolverlo por otra
vía no cabe se están bien han resultado
este con con situaciones es donde los
civiles están perdidos la vida decir es
casi una encerrona es donde los
organismos internacionales nos pueden
aportar por su propia estructura es una
solución posible claro y si las propias
resoluciones del consejo de seguridad
además no son vinculantes aparte de como
ha dicho la otan que otras acciones se
pueden tomar en casos como el de esta
guerra y otras que se alargan en el
tiempo
por ejemplo el hecho de que se hagan
algunos bloqueos económicos algunas
sanciones económicas pueden tener un
efecto en un corto plazo de alguna
manera pero son sanciones que tampoco se
pueden provocar en el tiempo porque por
ejemplo esas sanciones son una puerta
que no solamente se lesiona russián la
puerta tiene dos lados por lo cual
tampoco europa puede cobrar de unas
rusas y son sanciones que tampoco pero
esperan por la cual esté entre la
imposibilidad de la resolución de los
organismos internacionales y la poca
viabilidad en el tiempo de las
situaciones económicas quedamos casi a
manos de los políticos de turno una
situación absolutamente lamentable